[Music]  Blake Lively went all out for her press  tour in New York City rocking seven head  turning looks to promote her new film  all I see is you well I'm really lucky  to have access to really great designers  and but the 30 year old actress saved  her most comfortable look for a night  out with her husband Ryan Reynolds on  Monday  check out the superstar couple walking  hand-in-hand as they left a special  screening of the film the mom of two  flashed her toned tummy in a ripped  baseball jersey and snap of sweatpants  while keeping it glam with red pumps and  gorgeous hair and makeup meanwhile Ryan  coordinated with his fashionable wife in  a navy trenchcoat and slacks and she  really does just show me how to be  better in almost every way as a father  as a person everything